Good morning, my name is Rob Phillips
and I'm from Caltech. Today, I'm at Woods Hole in
Massachusetts. Super privileged to be here. And
I'm going to be talking about great questions in
the life sciences. And these are questions where it's
thought that maybe physics and computation will be able
to shed some interesting light. Now the question I'm posing
today is, can we find a way to do what I would call,
decipher the modern Rosetta Stone? Here are just
to give you a sense, a historically inaccurate sense,
of the rosetta stone and its history. The basic story goes
something like this. Napoleon had grand ambitions, he decided
to go to Egypt, and when he got there, his soldiers they
ransacked the place. And one of the things that happened is
they found this rock, the Rosetta Stone. It led to a variety
of geniuses, such as Thomas Young, known for his study of
interference of light. And Champollion to decipher
the Rosetta Stone. Of course, from a historical, from an
archeological perspective, this is clearly a very interesting
thing. But, I would say that at the moment, we're living through
an era where there are much bigger fish to fry. There's
much more sort of demanding set of questions of
deciphering something. And that's that we're living in
the genomic era. So, the question that I'm going to pose
today has to do with, okay, we can now more or less
at will, sequence genomes. We can sequence genomes
of human beings and a generic organism that we discover.
Bacteria, whatever. What this leads to is long strings
of letters, A's, T's, G's, and C's. But it does leave us
wondering, what does it all mean? Now the thing I'm
try to do in this talk is to give a sense of the extent to which
we successfully had a translation, like that that I showed you
here. Which is, it is a sort of translation table for the Rosetta
Stone. And the extent to which there are gaping holes
in our understanding of this information content of genomes.
So, to go back to the 1960s, I want to tell you a little bit
about what I think is one of the greatest experiments that was
ever done. In any science. This was done by Matthaei
and Nirenberg, and it has to do with cracking the genetic code.
The idea is that after the elucidation of the structure of
DNA by Watson and Crick, so 1953, there was a ten year
rush, 15 year rush, to figure out what does the sequence
of letters A, T, C, and G signify? And the reason that this is
as I would say interesting in a certain puzzle is that we
know that there are four nucleotides, A, T, G, and C, as I
already mentioned. And we also know that a typical
protein has on the order of 300 amino acids. Now if it takes
3 nucleotides to code for each amino acid, then that means
a typical sequence, a nucleotide sequence, is around
4^1000 different possibilities. It's a huge combinatorial
space. And the question they set themselves was,
how do we tame that huge complexity and beat it down
into a form where we would actually have some sort of
translation table? The way this experiment happened
was synthetic biology, if you like, it wasn't called that
at the time. But what they did was they synthesized mRNAs
that were repetitive, U-U-U-U-U and so on. And then they
fed these mRNAs to a cell extract and asked the question,
which of the radiolabeled amino acids are incorporated in
the protein? And what they found is a chain,
phenylalanine-phenylalanine-phenylalanine-phenylalanine
and so on. And the consequence was that they cracked the
genetic code. By doing this repeatedly, they were able to
essentially figure out the entire genetic code. So a way to
think of this, most people have seen this before, you start
from the inner circle, that tells you the first codon, the first
letter, then you go to the next circle out, that tells you the
second one, the third circle out tells you the third,
and if you look at that triplet and then that will tell you
on the fourth ring, which amino acid goes with that collection
of nucleotides. The reason I say in the title that this is only a
partial vocabulary, is that it is in a certain sense deceptive.
It makes it sound as though we've cracked this Rosetta Stone,
when in fact, we really haven't. The reason I say that is
illustrated I think, even in the case of the supposedly best
understood organism, which is the bacterium, E. coli.
If you go look at the databases of what we know about
E. coli, what you'll find is that 2000 of the roughly 4500
genes have no regulatory annotation. Now what do I mean
by that? What I mean is that, we indeed know where genes
start. We indeed know that certain amino acids will be
reduced and strung together as a result of that gene. But what we
know nothing about is the decoration of the DNA in front of that
gene that tells it whether it should be on or not, in the first place.
In other words, it's regulated. And we really don't know how
that works. In the case of eukaryotic cells, animal cells,
the situation is even worse, as shown by the lower diagram
here. What that is, is it's showing a hunk of genomic DNA
and this green part is known as an enhancer. Enhancer refers
to a little chunk of DNA that can be as far away as megabases
from the gene it controls. And then it bends over and kisses
its regulatory region onto the basal transcription apparatus
and turns the gene on. The problem is, if I handed you some
genomic sequence and said, okay, you tell me where the
enhancers are and you tell me which genes they interact
with, it would be very hard at best. Okay, so I claim that
this means we really haven't cracked the full genetic
code. And so, this is to me really the great question of
this particular talk. But I want to tell you a little bit about
approaches that have been taken. This is from an experiment
that was done by Justin Kinney and his PhD thesis work, which I
think is really quite cool as a way of looking forward to
own the genome with single base-pair resolution. So I show
in this diagram, I have some promoter, some region of DNA
that controls the gene that I'm interested in. I want to figure
-- and I don't know what the regulatory behavior is,
I want to find that out. So how do we do that? His idea was,
let's take the DNA and mutate it at about 10%, in other words,
10 out of every 100 bases will screw up. We'll change them
from A to T, and A to G, and so on. And then we'll ask the
question, if we wire up cells, each cell having a different version
of this mutagenized promoter, how much fluorescence does this
cell produce? The fluorescence is used as a way to read
out how much we've messed up the gene. And so as shown in this
diagram, he makes a library of what are called plasmids, these
are small circular DNA with his gene of interest. Mutagenized
gene, the cells are fluorescent. Then what he does is
sorts the cells according to how much fluorescence they have, that's
what you see here, the sorting scheme. And then categorizes
them according to how high or low their fluorescence is
and that's the point of this bottom diagram. The group called
B1, B2, B3, and so on, those are bins in which the cells
have different levels of fluorescence. And each collection
has a different fluorescence. So that's the key idea.
For me, where physics and sort of theory meets this kind of
experiment is this graph shown here in the upper right.
Which tells us the relationship between sequence and
which bin a given cell got sorted into. Let me try and give you
an analogy. I'm in a room right now, there's a door, if someone
were to walk in the door right now, I could make a guess
about the height of that person. How might I do that? Well
I would just reason, well, typical human beings are between
5' and 6' feet tall, I would do something along those lines.
If somebody told me the next person to walk in is going to be
a woman, then I would do much better on localizing that person's
height. Now why is that? It's because there's what's called a
mutual information between height and gender. Just like in this
case, there's a mutual information between which base,
is it an A, a T, a G, or a C, at a given site. And which bin
the cells will be sorted into. So, what comes out of this
is what's called an information footprint. Ideas that tells
you what bases, at least the ones labeled in orange,
which bases are the ones that are important for gene expression.
And so, what you can do with this method is, you can take -- go to
a region of the genome which you're ignorant about, and you can
figure out where transcription factors will bind. And you can start
to decode this next layer of information that's hidden in the genome.
So, let's think about this. What I've told you is that there's a challenge,
first of all, we really don't understand the genome in detail at the
-- at all levels of information. But let's say we solve the problem
in the -- using the type of scheme that I just talked about.
Then what I would say is, we have a translation table
like this picture that I showed you earlier, which comes from Champollion,
which was basically telling us the meaning of the symbols
in the hieroglyphics. But what I want you to consider is, having
the list of symbols, if I knew the letters in the English alphabet,
and even perhaps, if I knew the meaning of, if I had words in
the English alphabet, that doesn't imply that I'm ready to write
a novel. So the vision that I really want to finish with is,
let's say that one solves this problem of figuring out what the
genome says at the level of the words, how do we compose
a genomic novel? That's the question that I want to think about.
So, in order to argue this, I want to go back in a way to
engineering in the physics setting. I think of engineering
as synthetic physics, and the reason I put the word "synthetic" in there
is because I want to conjure up images of synthetic biology.
So, engineering is synthetic physics. And often what one
does is the simple problem first, a toy problem. You don't work on
the airplane wing first, you work on flow past a sphere or flow past
a cylinder, and you work out the rules of that problem and then
once you have those rules in hand, then you turn to the more
complicated situation. So the beauty of the picture I'm showing
above is, this is the kind of thing that Leonardo Da Vinci was already
thinking about. He was curious about flow past a sphere, he was able
to draw the vortices that you see in the picture. And my point is that
after 150 years of fluid mechanics, we started understanding
things well enough to then say, let's try to use these principles
for something more tricky, which is for example, the shape of
an airfoil. I love this picture, which shows, it's a Boeing picture,
which shows a 747 and a 787. Really gives you a sense of
where we've come with engineering. And the dream I guess
I would like to articulate for biology is to have a biological
engineering that bears the same relationship to fundamental
science that this kind of thing in mechanical and electrical
engineering do to physics. So, in a certain sense, what I would like
is I'd like to be able to write the novel of the anglerfish. So the idea
is, I could go grab a fish, sequence its genome, be able to
put the sequence into a computer to read it and say, "Okay, those
are the genes, these are the regulatory regions, these over here
are, in a certain sense, DNA fossils. And now I will reprogram
this fish so that the color of the light that comes out of its little
thing on its head is different." That's a vision for synthetic biology
that would really be based on the infrastructure in deciphering
the genomic Rosetta Stone. In summary, what I've tried to say,
I think is a great question of our time, is the search to decipher
these genomic Rosetta Stones. We've already learned a lot,
but I think that in a certain sense, Thomas Paine once said,
a long habit of thinking a thing wrong gives it a superficial
appearance of being right. A long habit of thinking that we
understand genomes and we've cracked the code gives it a
superficial appearance of having been solved, but I think
really, it hasn't. And so, to me that's one of the great questions.
So I close by just saying it's a subjective matter, this issue of what are
great questions. But that's the privilege of doing science, is that we get to
ask questions that interest us and we're able to go pursue them.
Thanks for listening.